we're trying to create some laws really
because at the moment
um if you're separated dad
you've got no rights in law to see your
children
which is astonishing
the government's position is that they
do not believe what's called a legal
presumption of contact would be helpful
and that means that your only right is
to make an application to court to see
your children some fathers get confused
because you've got parental rights
responsibilities so if your name is on
the birth certificate you'll have those
automatically but they are very very
pitiful and very limited they're going
to give you rights to educational and
medical information it does not give you
in writing law to see your children the
presumption of the courts is such that
the children live in the mother
automatically that is the Assumption of
assumption
um and that the father as I said will
need to make an application Accord to
see his children and he'll need to go
for a safeguarding process
where safeguarding checks are carried
out to be fair on both parties but the
treatment of farmers is fundamentally
discriminatory it's fundamentally in
breach of their right is fundamentally
in breach of the human rights of a child
to see their father to enjoy not just
the uh presence and involvement of the
father but the paternal family
Eternal forever you know the
grandmothers grandfathers Aunts Uncles
everybody else who can support that
child
um so it's a really difficult and
troubling system uh I said it's
completely secretive
um there is no accountability no
transparency we have an unelected
unaccountable Judiciary operating in
complete secrecy even Kim Jordan would
probably Flinch at the idea there's a
sub form of Justice what do you mean by
that well I just mean it's the level of
secrecy is is astonishing so I kind of
want to I want to take a step back just
because
there's a lot to take in yeah so so if I
if I was to have a child with someone
okay yeah and we
then we separate we break up he has no
legal rights to the child correct none
so if he were if you were to separate if
he's on the birth certificate he gets
the education right so he gets seek his
good information about education and
information about medical oh but it's
just information no no say I I still get
to choose where the kids go to school
the child lives with you sister father
what normally happens the father will
leave the house
and as soon as the father leaves the
house because he thinks he's doing the
right thing this is what I call Sagal ad
syndrome so we think we're doing the
noble thing we're doing the right thing
but if the father relationship breaks
down and he thinks oh it's all good to
be living together the father will
generally be the person who leaves the
house unfortunately when he does that
his rights go up in smoke like that oh
Susie leaves because when he's living
together with the mother uh there's a
presumption of share care as soon as he
leaves mother becomes the parent with
carer isn't a parent he becomes the
non-resident parent with no lawful
rights what if what if it was the other
way around would it switch or no well if
the child was living with the father
then the father would be
um effectively become the resident
parent a Mum would become the non-muslim
parent but I say that is very very rare
what percent of the time does that
happen less than one percent less than
yeah
when women we can be spiteful stuff
women are
up you know can be predatory of become
far more predatory
sexually in terms of relationships the
informality you can meet somebody a
couple of clicks online relationships
are more disposable
um well who wants inconvenience of that
in a father right you know that's what
it comes down to who what who wants the
inconvenience of having a father around
the mother won't care for or doesn't lie
always resentful against because maybe
the father's being unfaithful maybe he's
done something wrong maybe he's not
enough money you know far better just to
airbrush the father out and that is the
reality of our society today it's
disposable and that's why we've got over
three million kids living in fabulous
homes in this country yeah you've said
one out of three children live without a
father wow I didn't realize it was that
high this is this is a pandemic it's off
the charts and obviously what that
creates is the whole list of
consequences you've got in in this area
like in in East London you've got all uh
feral Estates with fell boys you know
young boys roaming around whose only
Father Figure is a local gang leader or
is the local drug dealer
um for poor girls whose first experience
in often over man is a sexual one
because a father hasn't been present so
this cycle of fatherlessness condemns
our children to you know anti-social
Behavior to end it actually ended up in
the very cause that separated them from
their fathers in the first place that's
the [__] Paradox here so okay so back
to if so he leaves the house then what
what's the next thing that happens well
he'll want to see the children and then
and then oftentimes as I found out the
women will say no yeah right the women
will say no for anyone of a multiple
number of reasons but they are
unfortunately the law empowers women to
deny tax access to the kids and what
they effectively do and what the mothers
are doing
and it's appalling because this is
emotional abuse they're actually
weaponizing the children
they're turning the children to a weapon
to punish
their former partner to punish the
children's father to separate them it's
the cruelest thing you could do
what's the word punishing somebody that
you hate the most is to stop them seeing
the people they love the most and that
I'm afraid and I've been doing this 21
years we've had over a million inquiries
there are tens of hours of cases
and I I can tell you from my own
personal experience of dealing with that
volume of cases that is a reality
um and it's it's it it's tragic because
a system literally encourages mother
knows to do that encourages others to
make false allegations so we live in an
age where
um to get legal aid for a mother to get
legal aid she has to make allegations of
domestic abuse or coercive controlling
Behavior or whatever it's going to be in
these days I don't really get what uh
coercive controlling Behavior or she can
make allegations no you said she makes
allegations why to get legal aid to get
legal aid to gain the system
so as legal is that the same thing like
benefits here yeah it's like free free
legal aid free legal so she will have a
solicitoring cause you have a barrister
called most fathers won't get legal aid
like the vast majority of weight so the
father it's there's no equality of arms
no quality of arms it's completely
one-sided the fathers effectively like
handcuffed with his hands tied behind
his back the mother will get legal aid
if she makes even the flimsiest of
allegations literally any allegation is
taken at face value in a family cause
so this is where to some extent this is
fed through into the me too moment but
it started in the Family Justice System
was where you can now
it's a bit like a sailing Witch Hunt I
went to Sega a few years ago it's quite
interesting and looking at the history
of that but now it's the witches doing
hunting so you could just point a finger
at something and go this happened and
the courts will take it as Bible truth
so and to the fathers then the
obligations down to the father to have
to disprove an allegation and what that
comes down to does it require any
evidence it's decided and civil court on
the balance of probability I.E whose
evidence the judge prefers and let me
just finish this point
the reality is when a judge is faced
with a mother
who will often be behind a screening
court because she's always terrified of
her father
she's behind the screen and she's crying
and she's rocking her back forwards
walking batters and forwards would the
judge prefer her testimony or the
testimony of the big ugly area I'll blow
in the other corner and 9.9 times out of
ten the judge will go with the mother do
the judges ever like wise up to this and
start to think no so I'd imagine if
you're doing this 20 like if you're a
20-year judge right I would imagine that
you you it's kind of like I've been
doing this show for a year and a lot of
men's complaints when I started the show
I didn't really understand then I do the
show for a year
thank you
give fathers the kids
oh my God I'm like but it's like it
changed your perspective like why don't
the judges I'd imagine they'd have to
there's no way they couldn't no like
have no idea that the women were lying
or some of them anyway you have to bear
in mind these are drastic judges
Jurassic Jurassic you know like that age
they're that prehistoric uh thinking
Stone Age courts they are indoctrinated
they have an indoctrination and they
believe this is the way it is
um that all men are practically violent
perpetrators so don't forget even even
it's not just the judges it's the entire
bureaucratic command structure of the
Civil Service of the ministry of Justice
um see what they've done is they've
reversed the basic tender Justice
innocent until proven guilty in a family
courts you were guilty until proven
innocent the burden of proof
should be on the court to demonstrate to
demonstrate you are a risk to your child
because they're just automatically going
to think she's telling the truth because
there's no truck there's no jury it's
just the judge
and so then he has to defend himself he
will go to often his allegations go to
What's called a fact find in here and
it's literally he says she says finding
hearing fact finding him okay and it's
literally he says she says okay so whose
testimony does the judge prefer and the
majority of the time they will go with
the mother and the mother will switch on
the Waterworks she'll be crying she'll
be in distress she'll be saying how
terrible her life is
um and the reality is I'm afraid uh
quite often the complete opposite of
that
um but there is no the father these are
Farber phobic course like all
pharmacobic because they are
institutionally discriminator against
men on the basis of like my [__]
gender on the basis I've got a million
two veg I mean I went for it 21 years
ago
upsets me you know that I went for it to
try and see my childless boys so yeah
it's heartbreaking
pretty difficult so which is why
foolishly uh I'm still here yeah I'm
still here because I'm a father of three
boys 26 25 and and 17 and you know
they've had some issues and they're
growing up and it's a difficult age to
be
um a young man or a boy really difficult
age you know current climate and and so
I feel
a duty of care to them but also I feel
strongly
um about this is this is something which
is you know from here and um somebody's
got to do something about it you know so
so I'm I'm still I was in a high court
the other day and I've been threatened
with imprisonment I've been afraid of
content to call proceedings in jail for
for what uh for publishing information
about court case
and uh the judge has said to me the
other day and I was drug fathers are
just me were dragged into the high court
on this case
and she's ordered me to stay take stuff
down off the Internet it's just a a
judge in in the high court in in London
why were so I don't
I'm not like illegal yeah I don't know
are you not allowed to like make those
well no because the corpse is Secret
really it's a secret but what they do
occasion they'll publish selective
judgments like either to make the father
look bad or they'll publish the excerpts
what I want and I'm insistent upon oh
guys my [__] grave right is that
every core door is open every window is
[__] open and they are exposed to the
disinfectant of sunlight and we have
proper accountability we have proper
transparency so we can see what is
happening behind closed doors
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we demonetized on a daily basis
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible